Assassin's Creed unity is the newest
installment and the popular Assassin's
Creed franchise and you guys haven't
asked me to play these games for a while
so I checked out a few of them first and
over the past week I played unity and
I'm here to tell you guys my full
thoughts on this game that may not be
entirely finished in this game you play
as Arno who is basically the spider-man
of the French Revolution that's right
he's extremely good at modern-day
parkour he can do just about anything he
can jump off a building and land
directly on a rope I mean this guy is
basically he's a god and you play a
theme throughout this game as he
encounters romance sword fights and a
lot of crowds now before I get into my
full review I just want you guys know I
didn't hate this game it's not a
terrible game at all there's some really
great things about it for instance the
graphics are absolutely stunning the
city of Paris is breathtaking there are
so many hidden details to be found in
this game in the building's the
architecture and the many different
people that fill this city it's all very
extraordinary what they're able to
accomplish with the graphics of this
game it's really beautiful looking the
voice acting and the sound is also very
good and a lot of the character models
are excellent you can really see emotion
in their faces and that is definitely
worth praise but I think the main issue
with unity that myself and a lot of
other players have encountered is the
control scheme and a lot of glitches and
bugs that kind of make the experience
rather unnerving I was actually able to
capture a lot of gameplay footage of my
experiences with glitches like at one
point the camera actually attached
itself to the ceiling and I was able to
move along the ceiling in this room for
a long time before it finally zapped
back down to my character I got stuck in
this weird void by a building where I
couldn't move and there are many times
where you're trying to jump off of
something where your character just
attaches himself to a random pole or
something and it's really difficult to
move there were many times in which I
tried to draw my sword why I press
square over and over again and the sword
would not draw I was once following
someone who disappeared right before my
eyes and did not come back there are so
many glitches in this game that it's
honestly kind of broken and the worst
part was some of those glitches weren't
just annoying they actually made it so I
couldn't progress and I had to actually
restart because there were certain
people that I was supposed to be looking
for that actually vanished from
since I couldn't complete the objective
there are also times when the game
throws up instructions to parry or dodge
and when you do parry or dodge it
doesn't work or it tells you to parry or
dodge when you're not actually supposed
to so you're just kind of running and a
guy has a sword nearby and it says parry
and you just go like this really quick
and there's nothing happening you're
like oh I guess I'll just keep running
these are little nitpicks but when they
continuously happen over and over again
during your gameplay experience it can
get rather annoying one cool feature
throughout the game is that sometimes
law officials will mess with you they'll
get annoyed with you they'll push you
out of the way if you draw your sword
then they get really upset but sometimes
some kind of ruffian citizens will help
you actually against these law officials
that happened to me once or twice I was
like forget this guy and I just like
slicing with my sword and this other guy
was like yeah half the police I'm just
like sliced up doing I was like okay
cool and whenever you draw your sword in
a crowd people get really scared which
caused some unintentionally hilarious
moments now in regards to a lot of these
bugs that I've been mentioning Ubisoft
has publicly acknowledged them in a list
which you know I guess that's kind of
cool that they are aware of it but it's
kind of strange that you would release a
game that's not finished that is filled
with so many bugs I mean I don't
understand how you can sit there and
play a game and counter these various
things and like yep we'll put that on
the shelves because Assassin's Creed is
definitely a franchise that has like
hardcore built-in fans that will buy
every single game no matter what and
with unity it feels kind of like they
got to that point where they're like
well we can put this one out on the
shelf and maybe on day one or day two
we'll release an update or a patch for
the game to fix a lot of these things
which they've done in which they're
doing but it's just kind of silly that
you pay $59.99 for a game that's not
entirely finished yet it is fun though
to run through a very well realized city
of Paris with tons of different things
you can do but a lot of it is just
running to set destination running to
this destination and you can't swing
there like spider-man or use your powers
like an infamous so you just kind of run
through a whole bunch of crowds and the
collision detection isn't very good and
sometimes that can get really cumbersome
overall I wouldn't really recommend
unity if you've never played an
assassin's Creed game before if you want
a next-gen experience
with the franchise I'd recommend the
much better Assassin's Creed Black Flag
you get to be a pirate which is kind of
amazing
I think hardcore fans of the franchise
will be disappointed in the structure of
this game in fact I know a lot of them
are I've even talked to a few them that
we're like yeah this is probably one of
the worst games in the entire franchise
that being said I'm gonna give
Assassin's Creed unity at five point
five out of ten because the graphics are
stunning the character models are
excellent it's not like at a superman 64
level of broken but it's not a finished
game and it requires a lot more patches
and a lot more fixes before it can be a
fully enjoyable game which is stupid
because I can go to Walmart or Best Buy
right now and buy it so it should be
finished guys I'm super excited because
tonight at midnight I am picking up
Super Smash Brothers for the Wii U and
though my goodness gracious its I can't
wait so I'll have a review for that
after I play the single-player for a
while and I play it with friends because
you can't review that game until you
play some serious hardcore multiplayer
so I'm looking forward to that and I'm
planning something a little bit special
with that game
perhaps a recorded matchup with somebody
that you might enjoy watching I don't
know it might happen it might be awesome
I hope you guys like it as always guys
thank you so much for watching and if
you like this you can click right here
and get stuck man eyes
[Music]